hey 42 here this riff will be a bit
different to normal
I recently reached a hundred thousand
subscribers thanks to you guys I
couldn't have done it without every
single one of you thank you for watching
liking commenting and sharing to
celebrate this riff will be facts about
myself I asked you on Facebook and
Twitter what you really want to know
about forty two so here we go
I'll start from the beginning Kym and
Matt asked me why did I start this
channel for as long as I can remember
I've been interested in facts the more
useless the better
I've always researched and ask questions
about absolutely everything when I come
across something in life that I don't
know or understand I have to know why
when who and what is it all about so a
couple of years ago I thought why don't
I share my passion for knowledge with
the world and along the wave I can make
a living out of doing what I love
well then isn't that everyone's dream
when I uploaded my first video my
expectations were low the idea of more
than ten people watching it seemed alien
to me I was in no way prepared for the
enormity of views that followed over the
next year and I still can't quite
believe my good fortune Evan Wright
asked where do I live I grew up in and
to this day still live in a region in
the north of England called Lancashire
which is famous for bringing the world
the Industrial Revolution and the
Beatles Laura and Ally asked how old am
I thanks for asking
I'm 22 Morgan Jerome asked what is my
favorite food that's a tricky question
but it probably Marmite on toast it's
really popular in the United Kingdom
what if you never tasted it before
people paid for a shock mark planner
asked how many people are working on the
show well it's just me from research to
design filming and editing I'm all on my
own
of course I have the moral support of my
fans and my family and friends whom all
motivate me to make my videos as good as
they possibly can be
Steve canceled asked what did I study at
university and what is my day job I
didn't go to university
was never a possibility for me not
because I couldn't but because I didn't
want to which may come as a surprise
from someone who claims to be so
enthralled by knowledge and facts but I
have always preferred to carve my own
way through life from the moment I left
college I was determined to do something
significant and most importantly do
something that I loved to me university
seemed like an impediment of that goal
the skills I have learned have all been
self-taught so do I have a job
yes it's called 42 before I started this
channel I managed a small team in the
advertising department
of a retail company but I quit that job
to start 42 because I wanted to do
something I enjoy and advertising wasn't
it
it was an enormous risk but I couldn't
be happier doing anything else than
making interesting videos about the
weirdest and wackiest topics I can
possibly think of and the fact that so
many people enjoy watching my videos is
more fulfilling than any day job I
previously had could have ever offered
Tim best asked what was my favorite
subject in school my favorite subject
was physics but I also really enjoyed
art to this day I still draw a lot in my
spare time Mary asked who is my favorite
scientist I don't believe one can be
called the best or the greatest but my
personal favorite is Stephen Hawking
whom despite immense difficulties has
pioneered some of the greatest
scientific discoveries the world has
known Hawking has done incredible work
on black holes over his lifetime which
is a personal interest of mine Billy
Stanley asked how do you think up such
thoughts is it down to research of prior
knowledge well honestly it's a mix of
both like I mentioned earlier I have
always had an insatiable appetite for
knowledge and learn
but I can't for a moment pretend that I
already know every fact that I put into
my videos an awful lot of research goes
into creating each episode which I
thoroughly enjoy because I learn a lot
of new things along the way
Taylor Wyler and John asked where did
you come up with the name 42 it's a pun
the comedy science fiction series The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy by
Douglas Adams suggests that the answer
to the ultimate question of life the
universe and everything is simply 42
this anecdote has since found its way
into international geekdom and it is a
popular joke amongst geeks and science
fiction fans the world over that the
universally accepted answer to the
question of the meaning of life the
universe and everything is 42
even Google agrees when you google the
answer to life the universe and
everything
Google's calculator will present you
with the number 42 so yes Kristen Graff
I am secretly saying 42 and finally Alex
gambler 182 Malone Thomas and Jonathan
or last what's my real name my name is
Aaron spelt with a double R which is of
Scottish origin the name originates from
the Isle of Arran
I want to finish by thanking you all for
your support it really wouldn't be
possible without you so thank you and of
course thanks for the view subscribe for
more thoughty2